ce type de plateau on devrait bientôt ne
plus le voir du tout dès le 1er janvier
2023 les restaurants n'auront plus le
droit d'utiliser de la vaisselle jetable
à table voici ce qui change concrètement
quels sont les objets qui vont être
interdits la mesure concerne les
assiettes et plus largement les
récipients comme les cartons de burger
de friture les cornets de frites les
boîtes à pizza ou à sushi les gobelets
et les couverts et les couverts qui sont
en plastique en carton ou d'autres
matières tout seront interdits à partir
du moment où ils sont jetables
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ne servent qu'une
seule fois l'interdiction concerne les
repas et boissons servis sur place mais
pas les commandes à emporter autre
exception le papier peint autour des
sandwichs qui permet son maintien sera
toujours autorisé quels sont les
restaurants visés selon le décret
d'application l'interdiction
s'appliquera à tous les restaurants
pouvant servir simultanément au moins 20
personnes sur place en pratique ce type
de vaisselle jetable est surtout utilisé
dans les fast food soit environ 30 000
établissements de ses tailles en France
par quoi ça va être remplacé certains
fast-food ont déjà présenté une nouvelle
vaisselle et l'on mise en place dans un
certain nombre de leurs établissements
concrètement quel que soit la matière
ils doivent désormais être réutilisables
ça veut dire qu'après avoir servi
l'enseigne doit les récupérer les laver
pour les resservir à d'autres clients
comme dans un restaurant classique ou en
sont les différentes chaînes j'ai
contacté plusieurs fast food pour le
savoir il y a d'abord ceux comme
McDonald's ou Burger King qui prévoit
d'être prêt en janvier de 2023 chez
Subway on plante sur un déploiement
effectif fin décembre 2022 et chez
Domino's Pizza qui compte beaucoup moins
de place assise un déploiement pour le
premier trimestre 2023 selon le
ministère de la transition écologique à
BFM TV des enseignes ont bien anticipé
l'interdiction d'autres viennent de le
découvrir ou feignent de le découvrir
deux choses à surmonter sont mises en
avant par plusieurs fast food déployez
des systèmes pour pouvoir laver et
sécher ces nouveaux contenants et
trouver des solutions pour que ces
contenants ne soient pas jetés ou
emportés par les clients dans une
tribune cinq ONG jus jusque
l'application a menacé par certains
acteurs de la restauration rapide et
demande au gouvernement de mettre en
place toutes les conditions pour assurer
le bon déploiement le décret prévoit une
amende de 1500 euros en cas de non
respect à BFM TV le gouvernement indique
durant la première année de rodage nous
allons privilégier une approche
pédagogique les sanctions concerneront
ceux de mauvaises volonté pourquoi ce
changement en fait cette mesure a été
prévue par une loi anti-gaspillage
adoptée en 2020 l'objectif est d'éviter
l'utilisation de milliers de tonnes de
plastique et de carton chaque année
selon le ministère de la transition
énergétique ambiant 180 000 tonnes
d'emballage et de vaisselle sont jeter
chaque année par le secteur de la
restauration rapide en France dont 55%
pour les repas sur place Burger King de
son côté estime que cette mesure leur
permettra d'éviter près de 1000 tonnes
de déchets par an en moyenne
plus globalement cette interdiction est
l'une des mesures qui vise à atteindre
l'objectif pris par la France de mettre
fin à tous les emballages plastiques à
usage unique décide 2040